what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got a ton of information
about the plot of secret invasion they
told us a ton of information about what
is going to happen in this series in a
new article by Vanity Fair so let's not
waste any time and jump right into it so
this article from Vanity Fair actually
gives us a ton of new information about
secret Invasion including why Nick Fury
no longer is wearing an eye patch in any
of these photos that we see him in now
of course they offer a logical
explanation as to why he is no longer
wearing the eye patch and it's a little
bit emotional as well however I believe
that this could be a lie it could be
Marvel Studios trying to trick us and
throw us off for a pretty decent twist
in the movie we'll get to that in a bit
as we go through these 10 new images and
details about the images and the new
characters that we are seeing and
breaking down what exactly they say
about these photos now the headline for
this article from Van Fair reads secret
Invasion revealed inside Samuel L
Jackson's eye-opening pun intended I'm
sure new Marvel series sub headline why
he has no eye patch where you've seen
Amelia Clarke's mystery character before
and 10 new images from the
shape-shifting alien Saga now based off
of everything that we've heard about
this movie and what they say in this
article this is going to be an alien
shape-shifting Espionage series which in
all honesty sounds like it's really cool
I know a lot of fans have been really
waiting for this series and this article
is going to get you even more excited so
right away it tells us the actual threat
of the movie it starts off by stating
who are you really that question is at
the core of the new Marvel series secret
Invasion which follows Samuel L
Jackson's spymaster Nick Fury as he
uncovers a conspiracy to quietly install
Double agents into positions of power
around the world now I automatically
know what everybody he is thinking but
Vanity Fair actually goes on to confirm
this they say in a traditional Espionage
story these might be operatives from
hostile rival Nations but in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the infiltration has
an otherworldly origin shape-shifting
green skinned extraterrestrials known as
skrulls who can perfectly simulate any
human being at will figuring out who is
who becomes especially daunting so there
you have it what we basically predicted
this entire time there are scroll out
there on Earth who are infiltrating the
world infiltrating very powerful
organizations all around the world
government organizations secret
organizations perhaps as well and maybe
even some superhero organizations
perhaps some of the Avengers that we've
known and love could end up being scroll
maybe not the entire time but maybe at
one point in time I'm sure they'll show
us some flashbacks of when the scroll
have infiltrated all of these huge
organizations so we'll definitely only
see about that what's interesting is
that when we left off with Captain
Marvel the first film The Scroll were
good and the cree were bad Marvel kind
of Switched that on us from the comics
but if the scroll are good why are they
infiltrating Earth well as with most
cases just because some people are good
doesn't mean that all of them are good
and they actually go on to tell us who
could possibly be the villain or at
least one of the antagonists of this
film and it could come in the form of
Amelia Clarke's character and it is
confirmed by Vanity Fair that she is
indeed playing a scroll the daughter of
Talos Gaia and here's where some of the
conflict actually starts to come in and
why some scroll aren't necessarily still
on The Human Side we have a new picture
of Nick Fury and Talos embracing each
other and touching their foreheads
together Samuel L Jackson explains
that's a scroll greeting I hadn't seen
him in a while now what's interesting
about this photo before we move on is
I'm not actually sure this is Nick Fury
this doesn't really seem like something
Nick Fury would do so this leads me to
believe that this could possibly be
talus's daughter Amelia Clarke's
character simply shape-shifted into Nick
Fury and she can't expose her true self
because some people might be around and
she can't expose that she is a scroll
now in the same time in this article
which we'll get to in a bit it does say
that Nick Fury is a little bit more
emotional and that he doesn't give a
anymore so this could simply just be a
new side of Nick Fury however it still
could possibly be his daughter Gaia but
Samuel L Jackson tells us more he says
he told the skrulls speaking about Nick
Fury that they were trying to find them
a place to live he promised them they
were going to find them a planet or
somewhere they could be and that's not
going so well then Ben mendelsohn who
plays Talos speaks about how there is
tension starting to grow between the
scroll and their Earthly allies and why
they are kind of starting to fight the
article says Talos himself breaks from
the talos-led faction to seize the
resources they need first quietly while
in Disguise then by force if needed the
storyline mirrors countless true stories
from actual history when displaced
groups have first fractured then lashed
out after patience and diplomacy are
exhausted Ben Mendelson says I think any
time that you get cultures that have
significant tensions between groups of
people then you can find a corollary the
Cold War stuff is the big one that jumps
out but there is plenty of strife
between groups of people that this
addresses so basically with what Sam
Jackson said and Ben mendelsohn said we
now know that the scroll have been
waiting for Nick Fury to find them a
place to live but they're growing
impatient and they need resources like
food and their patience has run out so
instead of simply waiting they are now
going to try and take the resources
themselves and sometimes if they get
caught or they can't exactly get what
they need in a piece useful way they do
it in an aggressive Way by force they
say which probably means if you get in
their way they'll kill you this is where
the article goes on to say the conflict
is not just geopolitical it's personal
one scroll radical Amelia Clarke's Gaia
has issues with Palos that go far deeper
than most and here's where they confirm
who she actually is they say while this
is the Game of Thrones actor's first
appearance in a Marvel Studios project
her character has actually appeared
before when asked about Clark's
character Jackson pointed out a scene
from 2019's Captain Marvel in which Fury
Witnesses a reunion between Mendelson's
Talos and his long lost scroll family to
board a space station orbiting Earth
remember when Ben was there with his
wife and daughter Samuel Jackson says he
goes on and says she's the little scroll
girl grown up she's his daughter and it
sounds like she is pretty much a part of
a scroll resistance and that she's kind
of tired of both her dad and Nick Fury
the article States growing up amidst
constant War makes it hard to ever stop
fighting living in the shadow of a
powerful parent makes the situation even
more dire especially when they're a
leader who is seen as having failed
speaking about her father talus in
gaia's case resistance was virtually
inevitable she says it's hardened her
for sure there's a kind of punk feeling
that you get from this girl she's a
refugee kid who's had Talos for a dad
you know what I mean maybe the fact that
we didn't know he had a kid up until
this point tells you everything you need
to know about their relationship the
article continues and says Gaia is also
pretty much over her dad's friend Fury
and his fellow human beings she says
these people promised a lot of stuff a
long time ago and not a lot has happened
so understandably a certain amount of
resentment has been built there's a lot
of emotions that live within her there's
a lot of confrontational aspects to her
character that have come from
circumstances you understand why she has
the feelings that she does so they
basically confirmed that the scroll have
a resistance and it's kind of a
resistance towards some of the other
scroll and the humans and they actually
sort of introduce us to the leader of
the resistance they give us a picture of
Kingsley bin adir as gravic they say the
charismatic leader of the scroll
resistance in secret Invasion so expect
him to have a big part and it sounds
like Gaia is definitely a part of this
resistance now here's where Vanity Fair
starts to tell us a little bit more
about Nick Fury and how he is now we see
many new photos of him without his
classic eye patch on again this could be
because Emilia Clarke or another scroll
has shape-shifted as him and doesn't
have an eye patch but why they say the
reason they give for him not wearing the
eye patch anymore really is a pretty
strong story component they tell us Nick
Fury has been overdue for his own story
his introduction came in the very first
Marvel Cinematic Universe movie when
Jackson turned up in a post-credit
sequence to tell Iron Man you've become
part of a bigger Universe you just don't
know it yet over the next 15 years of
movies only scares details about Fury's
past have emerged we know he joined the
army straight out of high school that he
became a vital government operative Who
Rose to the highest level of Shield
before it collapsed and that he began
the Avengers Initiative because he
recognized that the threats to the world
were growing so big that the planet
needed to upgrade its superhero
protection policy but here's where it
gets pretty interesting Samuel Jackson
says even Nick Fury can be shaken you
know they say one reason his character
has been off in space ignoring calls for
help as he doesn't believe he can fix
things anymore Sam Jackson says he's up
there trying to process what the f
happened you know and what his place in
the world is the death of Iron Man the
death of Black Widow with that stuff
going on he just kind of checked doubt
which is why him not wearing an eye
patch anymore is actually a big plot
point in secret Invasion Samuel L
Jackson reveals that that is the
character's choice it's Nick Fury's
Choice he says he just doesn't wear the
patch the patch is part of who the
strong Nick Fury was it's part of his
vulnerability now you can look at it and
see he's not this perfectly
indestructible person he doesn't feel
like that guy and Jackson ends the
article by telling us some really cool
plot details about the movie he says
Nick had a whole scroll spy Network
because they could shape-shift and go
places that people couldn't they kept
their word they worked for him but he
hasn't done what he said he was going to
do they want a home they want to live
they want to live like they are they
want to live in their skin they don't
want to live in ours what he's not doing
is calling in his Super Friends so
that's part of the whole dilemma I mean
people want them and he's not bringing
them why you'll find out there's a very
good reason he's holding back Sam
Jackson says and I think and I think a
lot of fans probably think this as well
that's because he doesn't actually know
who a scroll is this could be the secret
Invasion them invading even the
superhero teams we know that Roadie war
machine is going to be in this we know
that other heroes are probably going to
be in this as well who could possibly be
a scroll that's the whole danger of
everything is you don't really know and
Sam Jackson doesn't really know as well
which is why he himself is probably
going to try to do everything himself
with Maria Hill of course Colby Smulders
is returning we get new pictures of her
and she says listen I would have loved
superpowers at some point but it's also
intriguing playing a human in this world
because you've made the choice to really
put your life in jeopardy this is a
Marvel story where the humans can shine
even though there are aliens there's
going to be extraordinary fight
sequences this is about people on the
ground talking to each other and
interviewing people and really doing
Hands-On work to get the information
needed so she is going to be his one and
probably only go-to the one person that
he could trust and we also get a new
still of Olivia Coleman's character she
has a high-ranking agent in the British
intelligence service who has a past with
Nick Fury the article says sometimes
she's working with Nick Fury and
sometimes she's working against him as
their goals either align or Collide so
there are definitely many different
factors to this upcoming show and it
sounds like it's really going to be
pretty deep which I actually think we
need for Marvel Studios right now a
little bit more of a mature show and I
think the whole plot that they've
basically just told us in this article
sounds very very exciting and I'm glad
this is sort of going to be an Espionage
Thriller but hey let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below what do you think let us know
everything please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
or breakdowns you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf